ayer Alemania Polonia y Ucrania
acordaron Establecer un centro de
mantenimiento de tanques leopard en
territorio polonés estos blindados Ya
empezaron a llegar a Ucrania desde hace
unas semanas y además en los últimos
días confirmó la recepción de sistemas
de defensa antiaérea mientras continúa
llegando la munición sin embargo qué
necesita Ucrania para lanzar la llamada
contraofensiva de primavera tan
anunciada
Hola buenas noches aquí desde España el
problema de la Guerra de Ucrania es que
se necesita una continua
aprovisionamiento de armas y logística
para poder enfrentarse al otro lado de
un país como Rusia que a pesar de sus
deficiencias a pesar de sus errores
cuenta con un potencial militar civil y
militar bastante avanzado para poder
crear la vuelta a este conflicto y poder
recuperar O al menos mantener una
estabilidad en el la frontera del
doombas necesitaría pues muchísima más
armamento y muchísima más preparación no
están preparados aún para manejar los
tanques leopard y para manejar del todo
las baterías antiaéreas que tienen y la
supremacía aérea y artillera que está en
Rusia tiene sobre Ucrania es manifiesta
por tanto necesitaría un apoyo decisivo
por parte de la otan cosa que implicaría
por tanto un enfrentamiento geopolítico
con con Rusia que en estos momentos está
dentro de la presidencia el consejo de
seguridad de Naciones Unidas por tanto
no contaría con el apoyo de de la de la
ONU y sería algo muy arriesgado para
Europa e incluso para Estados Unidos y
precisamente
hablando no de este mayor apoyo que
necesitaría Ucrania en términos
militares ahora los aliados occidentales
están divididos sobre el envío de
aviones de combate así como lo
estuvieron respecto al envío de tanques
que finalmente pues se aceptó Cuál es la
discusión ahora sobre los aviones de
combate y Cómo cree que va a terminar
lo que sea mandado son tanques para
poder defender de manera primaria todos
los avances de la Infantería pero no se
ha mandado suficiente estanques ni
tampoco las tropas ucranianas están
totalmente
formadas con capacidad suficiente 100%
para manejar estos estos vehículos
mientras por otro lado los t90 y 90 m
que tiene los rusos y se han calificados
como verdaderos tanquistas verdaderos
carristas y por tanto puede ser un
conflicto muy complicado evidentemente
estos tanques que llegan y llegarán Y
seguirán llegando deberían haber llegado
muchísimo Antes y querían que surtieran
efecto y ahora con la Aviación va a
pasar lo mismo la preponderancia el
predominio que tiene Rusia de los aires
no solo por los misiles sino por la
bio-ción Pues debería ser contrarrestada
por lo menos al menos con una un
centenar de aviones de combate primera
línea y eso ya formar a los aviones de
combate formar gente en vuelo de aviones
de combate dado que aquellos modelos
diferentes en la otan y cecillos a
Ucrania pues es muy complicado se darán
los aviones pero Rusia dijo que cuando
se entregara se entregara armamento que
fuera ofensivo y os lo considerarían un
atentado contra seguridad nacional y Por
tanto se
reservan el derecho al uso de cualquier
elemento de defensa o ataque para su
geopolítica Y eso implica o puede
implicar en un momento determinado el
uso de bombas químicas o guerra química
e incluso la pluma nucleares tácticas
por tanto es muy complicado muy
inestable lo que en estos momentos
estamos viendo en la frontera con con
Rusia en el doombat por parte de Ucrania
por parte de Rusia y por otro lado en
las últimas semanas también se han
publicado imágenes de trincheras en la
Península de crimea que habría estado
cavando el ejército ruso usted ve que a
corto plazo podamos digamos presenciar
una ofensiva ucraniana para recuperar la
Península de crimea
podrían intentarlo evidentemente pero
nadie y es lamentable decirlo así en el
caso de la tiranía de Putin nadie y que
tenga el número de bombas nucleares y la
superioridad aérea y de misiles que
tiene Rusia respecto Ucrania nadie que
tenga esa capacidad perdería un
territorio como como Crimen y lo
permitiría bajo ningún concepto por
tanto estaríamos hablando de una
escalada militar que hasta ahora no
hemos visto y a pesar de que está
acabando trincheras para la mejor
defensa de crimea por un intento más que
de recuperación sí de hostigamiento a la
Península de crimea por parte de las
tropas de Ucrania Pues no creo que
pudieran conseguirlo si no consiguen de
nuevo otra vez un apoyo masivo inmediato
y contundente por parte de la otan y eso
posicionaría a la otan contra Rusia y
sería posiblemente la tercera guerra
mundial
y Fernando le pido brevemente para
terminar entonces ante todas estas
dificultades que usted plantea Cuál será
el escenario que veremos en la guerra en
Ucrania en los próximos días en las
próximas semanas
desde hace mucho tiempo se habla de que
hay dos únicas salidas la única salida
más óptima sería llegar a un almisticio
un acuerdo en el que se impactara una
fronteras en el doombas en el que
Ucrania decide acceder o no recuperar
esas fronteras por ahora y Rusia se
comprometería no seguir avanzando en
esas fronteras para tener algo parecido
con el norte Corea del Sur y la otra
opción es que ambos se sentaron a la
mesa de negociación y ellos mismos
llegaran a un acuerdo esta segunda es
muy probable la primera apoyada por
china aprobada por la India aprobado
incluso por miembros de la Unión Europea
es lo más factible